[Music]
in just encase news justin bieber
submitted by derek from Pennsylvania oh
wow
creative North Carolina town is staging
and a cop apocalypse survival tips it
would be North Carolina survival test
doomsday prepper
which apocalypse there's so many I know
biblical Zambia Filippo Bambi's one
zombies apocalypse
that's a big deal Bambi's one so there's
this zombie survival event in North
Carolina and it's looking for volunteers
that are willing to chase humans who
sign up to fight for their life it's
healthy it is from Halloween its quad
board people the it will be this
tongue-in-cheek apocalyptic competition
stage on October 19th according to a
Parks Department release and they're
just saying that this is what they say
on the press release find out who on
your team has what it takes to endure a
zombie up and down and which ones are
zombie bait participating teams will
have 60 minutes to retrieve items needed
to survive a nights in a containment
zone this sounds like a marketing scheme
by a hospital to get more customers I
feel like so many people get injured
like a [ __ ] I'm like I needed
help with I remember they used to do a
Walking Dead like it's like a maze and
[ __ ] and then people could sign up and
be zombies and [ __ ] actually yeah no
Universal horror limits yeah they have
that but then they also have at the
place where we went they also do
peep-peep bowling it's called Hollywood
oh yeah you can actually do um you can
shoot zombies what the sport they really
liked airsoft airsoft well we figure all
that make sure make sure that you guys
subscribe
subscribe now so TIFF Cajon can't
remember if you subscribe now you're
gonna help TIFF remember and gather her
thoughts get everything together and we
need more subscribers so those
subscribers fuel her brain with memories
Thunder good energy and it will give me
words in my brain this is the this is
the equivalent of clap for Tinker Bell
because she's dying
do you believe in fairies right yeah
yeah it's not [ __ ] I don't know about
the clapping you've all year not a man
of culture they're so international I
would love to do this but this is a
fight to the death but not a real fight
for your life I mean I mean yeah that's
[ __ ] fun and then you get to see what
friends are gonna weed out when the real
[ __ ] hits the fan and you're like let's
not [ __ ] invite them over cuz they're
gonna oh we should invite them over so
that is dumb be bait yeah Jesus Can I
grab your dad dying this is zombie to
come and just jump on you know Nicky
I've already said they want to kill eat
themselves right could be the wall I'm
gonna push the three of you towards the
zombies the rest of us we get away if we
meet again
Gio can do like if I survive and we meet
again I will not forget what you did oh
that's fair that's fair that's fair but
that's the game plan though so you guys
know yeah yeah that is the game I got my
foot up here cuz Nikki did say that she
is the type to sacrifice yourself you
don't even deal it up with me but she
says that you will fight to the death to
keep her life dusters
ever tip but I only have two hands
you're not gonna do anything we hope all
my for you thank you thank you no sorry
Casey you're going in the budget we're
pushing all four of you [ __ ] by
default why would you sacrifice yourself
okay no zombie zombie apocalyptic
situation yeah it's just [ __ ]
horrible I don't see a way out like I
don't see us I don't see human surviving
so I'm like peace out [ __ ] oh so you
know there's this fight or flight right
they missed one thing and that's what
TIFF and Nikki are there's no zombie
it's just they know that a zombie
apocalypse is happening and they're
killing themselves and I'm like wait
times out can you kill yourself when we
need you the minute they see on the news
they get a gun out there like all this
is way too scary for me yeah yeah yeah
Nikki we'll do it together scary dude
what a waste what a [ __ ] waste we
would need you as fodder what's that
like if you're gonna go out that's when
you you know what that's how you'll go
to during the song apocalypse you'll be
asked me I'm like I'm like tip oh look
out after just after view and you're
like what forget it okay I'd get
frustrated there's a direction it's like
on that like I'm not even sure it's an
aquifer and if I don't know you feed to
another animal it's just like a
sacrifice Oh father Potter yeah wait was
father with the [ __ ] access not so
many words I don't
scam used to teach English in Japan yeah
right yeah
[Laughter]
I don't they just know so few words
that's why we are multiple bro I know we
know multiple or I know I just read it
Finn okay fine I don't know I'm so
defensive right now okay you can be
defensive guy maybe talk about it zombie
apocalypse
I only know whereas I care about I know
the word I just I know the word god
dammit
wait how did you say November November
November he's missing with two V's
usually but then if he knows what he's
doing they won't sit do you guys have
November in the UK no we actually don't
it's 11 months yeah so right now it's
like 2045 it's a whole lap yeah this
goes back speaking words have you heard
the term lining limey yeah no like dirty
stinking - do you guys know Oh yesa this
weekend gets like Brits that's what
that's like a sling for Brits cuz
apparently they used to is it like slimy
but not I don't know it's like they used
to suck on limes to prevent scurvy and
so people so sailors used to call
miami's oh it's just an old one though
yeah it's a little all right so back to
this like a swashbuckler it's a old one
[Laughter]
where'd you care about yeah
yeah it's a pirate turn so Japanese
there's so many words that I have no
idea what spoken about that's the thing
about being bilingual is you suck at
both yeah my excuse guys yeah we shot
got like that's why I'm against being
bilingual Nick he isn't hot [ __ ] no oh
she knows a few words yeah yeah she
knows how to make fun of her grandma's
accident I'll tell you that her Filipino
grandma she can do it
Spa that's cool so back to the zombie
apocalypse thing so they are saying that
the zombies will be taking people's life
flags so there will be Oh looks like for
bubble at zombie really dying no I'm not
gonna be tackling and stuff like resin
why not because if you run into the
woods it's I don't know a lot of people
people might be like Oh rape you know
the old I'm not a zombie yeah I'm
actually not a zombie yeah yeah so
they're saying winning teams of two to
four players must make it back to base
camp with at least one life flag and
their supplies to count as survivors and
then once they have the survivors and
they're gonna they're gonna determine
who the ultimate winner is by like
rattles oh it's like wargames
[ __ ] fun I love [ __ ] like that do you
get to have weapons
I hope they hide it everywhere and you
have to like find it while still trying
to save your life wait Hunger Games at
airsoft we hide the guns every that was
fun thanks man it's like everyone just
runs in and then you just gotta find ya
some people just have ammo or they just
have a knife yeah they see if that like
everything's scattered how do you know
when you shot somebody at airsoft
because just about honor honor system so
when you lit it hurt yeah cuz paintball
it's like yo I see that [ __ ] but then
some people wipe it off and the piece of
[ __ ] oh I've seen it I think I think Bob
before and I had this one [ __ ]
[ __ ] used to wipe it off oh I
think you
I say you work your huh no [ __ ] no I
have honor nice good for you man
I've never people does it hurt more than
airsoft oh yeah it's a different type of
paint like I feel like paintball is uh
you getting soft the but the airsoft is
my cup it's a sharper like rubber band
oh I'd rather take that one than yeah if
you're wearing a bow you don't feel it
yeah from paintball you can get [ __ ]
well yeah I'll break you go brick skin
yeah
yeah I think AC broke skin with airsoft
yeah I'll get the Ruhr t-shirt I got
shot in the finger oh I need gloves
gloves stuff like that oh yeah they're
saying the zombie volunteers ages 14 and
older and needed so imagine like a 14
year old kids getting punched cuz you're
supposed to care there's something in
the middle of the whole thing that's
exactly what I've been watching a
compilation of kids being taken to like
Haunted Hornets and stuff there's a dope
that take their [ __ ] kids like
six-year-olds and [ __ ] and they think
it's real like they're like so don't
abandon their mom and like when the
[ __ ] zombie comes out and you see I'm
going [ __ ] that is [ __ ] traumatic I
know
these haunted houses and like you know
those things that they put like a I
don't know like a coin or washer in a
cat to make all that all that noise he's
just getting the [ __ ] out of me and I
hated it my dad thought oh so far you
seem scared my head - my dad took me on
the Back to the Future ride when I was a
kid and Universal and there's a part of
it where there's lava and he's like hey
Steven that's real [ __ ] lava you fall
in there you're gonna be dead in second
you said lava lava I said yeah you said
lava and I said lava I did you're
slipping bro one time I good anyway can
we talk about fun stuff knowledge
Steve's not here
[Music]